okay what do ya be now again you didn't
have to draw a diagram they gave you one
right but every time you draw it it
gives you some insight into what's going
on and how the shape works and how
everything fits together okay our first
question is to get a volume okay now you
know everyone knew pretty much ever done
the grade knew I had to multiply
something right but the question is this
so many numbers here
what do you multiply by okay so okay now
let's think about this right there is
multiplication here but let's think
about what these numbers are right this
three it's a high four is this base here
these are all lengths aren't they right
now you can't add lengths to get a
volume because if you add you know this
length Plus this length and another yeah
you get perimeter white-shoe right it'll
go all the way around the shape okay
so addition would happen if we had like
different parts this volume that we
needed to piece together but in this
case it's all just the winding piece so
I need to look at this and remember this
is um what kind of shape is this you
guys let me give you the name today if
there's a triangle right but it's a
triangular something good it's a prism
now do you remember we sort of forms a
danger that time when I brought in a
prop to help you remember why is he
going to prison so the prop is a saw
right what does that have to do with
this yeah good so the idea is prisoners
out taking across nature Sasori across
now have a look where does the cross
section belong which way does it do I do
I cut this way why not why Cannot I cut
this way so yeah so yeah so for instance
if I cut this way this way this way this
way what am I gonna get I'm gonna get a
whole bunch of us I'm gonna get a whole
bunch of different sizes I'll get a
rectangle here see that and they don't
get a smaller rectangle and a smaller
rectangle and they'll be they'll get
lower and lower and all off okay but
they're all different that's the problem
right so it's not a prism that way I
need to soar
in a way that gives me the same shape
every time like a like a loaf of bread
you remember that okay so which way to
Mike hmm now I've been cut in half a lot
of different ways length ways it's like
well which other ways been lightly I
care all right so I'm gonna draw one in
for you okay he's one I can read your
mind it's a bit they go okay so you can
see again the diagram how helpful it is
because look look he's one cross-section
the one on the front okay you got one on
the back and then you got this way a
little bit all the same you see that so
that's what we've got to work out the
area of okay the volume is going to be
what is the area of that cross-section
that triangle that's the area of a
triangle say this triangle in the front
because remember it's a prism so this
should all be the same at least at the
fingers crossed all right what's the
area of a triangle yep huh times base
which is the four very good times high
which in this case is three good so
there you go that's the area of the
cross-section okay yeah there you go
okay so that's the first bit and then
you multiply by one more thing to get
the whole volume right since we're
cutting it this way you're gonna get a
slice here this is the dimension we're
cutting along so it'll be by six that's
what we're on yep
I'm not just cutting in huh I'm cutting
it all these different spots it's just
I'm not drawing one on that because my
diagram I'm feeling it yeah no that's
right I mean I'm gonna have one here as
well and then another one here I'm gonna
have a whole bunch all the way across
okay so you can see my triangular slices
of bread okay
all right now this number here a half by
four by three that's half by 12 or 12 is
C which coincidentally is also 36 it's a
volume so one of my units just look at
this
volume is always cute okay because it's
always three dimensions three dimensions
okay
all right the surface area we're gonna
have to do some more drawings so this is
that was planning let's have a go shall
we it's worth mentioning by the way
there's lots of different nets you can
draw for instance this is not the only
net of a cube right for instance like
see these bits right you would fold them
around okay
but these sides they don't have to be
there they can be in other spots right
so for instance this this would also be
so yeah it would look a bit trickier
default but you could still do it and
that's why some people have different
nets you might be seen next to someone
who's got one looks different to yours
but that's okay I'm gonna draw that
mainstream ones okay gonna be a bit
antique if sitting all right I think
most people start with the base the
thing on the bottom okay what are its
dimensions I may be sure that's what
shape is it what shape is the base it's
a rectangle good so what are its
dimensions four by six very good four by
six so you're looking down at it right
four by six celebrate
so this is the base I'm looking down the
top okay so then what you can do is take
this part this kind of slanted roof bit
I suppose and then yeah you're on your
unhinging if you like so it comes around
like this and becomes flat okay so if
I'm looking down this it's gonna be like
sir
all right again same question what are
its dimensions you still get the same
seat
yeah very good so you've got this part
here which has now come out onto the
floor okay so you got a five-day which
is why I've drawn it long time okay now
from here you can most people have
stopped here so let's go back further
what's going to happen what else comes
off the base it's not just this slanted
roof what else is coming off the base
yeah okay so I've got this part I'll
fold that one down as well and what is
its dimensions three and these are all
six yeah good okay I'm going all the
rectangular bits what's missing
okay where should I put them yeah most
most people have put them in here which
is fine you don't have to but it's a
good spot for it so it looks kind of
like this doesn't it yeah yeah happy
with that okay now I need some
dimensions here to see how if I fall of
this back up this side is going to match
up to this side isn't it they're both
three and it's all it's all symmetrical
okay happy times okay all right now that
you have all the pieces that was
actually the hard part most people's
trouble got the wrong answer because
they missed a piece right so getting it
all out like that that's the easiest way
to make sure you don't miss anything
okay now how look at this right see this
middle part you built it by putting in
three rectangles right when you put
three rectangles together what's the
whole shape it's written thank you so
therefore I can work out this whole
rectangle all at once save a bit of time
right the width here is six this is my
surface area so six times what's the
high
five four three so it's nine let's stay
with yourself
good okay so now I've done that whole
rectangle
what should I add to that what should I
add okay
how many triangles do I have two of them
right and now here's the great thing
right you already looked at the triangle
didn't she look here he is right that's
the area of the triangle it's the
cross-section yeah so you can just pop
that in half times four times three
areas so you got six by 12 which is
who's good with the times those six
times seven plus double six we cannot do
that that's 12 which gives you a four
it's a surface area so the units should
be squared very good